after lunch so our next speaker is
shanghua he is a junior fella here he is
he was years away not years ago he was a
little while ago a student of Peter
Keynes was a postdoc there and is now a
junior fella and he's actually on the
job market so if any of you have jobs he
might be interested
right
um thank you everyone for being here uh
so
um and I also like to take this
opportunity to thank the organizers for
organizing this uh fantastic Workshop I
learned a lot and uh and thank the
organizers for inviting me to speak here
so today I would like to share some
initial investigations and this is also
part of my learning process of starting
uh epidemic models where we identify a
connection between the academic models
and the neural networks which to me is
fascinating so this is going to work
with peterkinson
okay so I will
um briefly or like spend some time to
explain what are the type of wire spread
model networks that I will be talking
about and then with a different view of
the same model that leads to a neural
network representation and then we will
discuss the properties of this uh model
which we call it a transmission neural
networks short for transnet and as both
as very smart models and there's
learning models and then I'll conclude
the talk and discuss some ongoing
investigations
so as we know when we study very spread
models on networks the local graph
structure are actually very important in
practice for example when we do context
tracing after we identified an infected
individual we do an interview to
identify who the person has actually in
contact with and then we inform those
people who have potential exposures and
ask them to um
to isolations or do a test another
example is a ring vaccination if we
identify an infected source and we do we
can do a strategy where a vaccinate its
immediate neighborhood or second Hub
neighborhood so in this way we can
contain the virus on a local scale
another example is that's actually used
in practice is this code with exposure
notification system which is a mobile
application on your phone and to the
user Bluetooth signals to identify
distance between individuals and for
people who are using this application if
they test the positive and Report the
result to the system and then the others
who are in contact with this person will
receive a notification saying that you
have potential exposure and then you
should either do test or do
self-isolation
uh another related but in a different
context is computer viral spread where
we have some sort of idea of how the
computer are connected so they're uh on
the computer network and if there are
some
um source of infection we can predict or
estimate the probability of the some
computers that have vulnerable to attack
so all these examples uh use uh sunshot
of the underlying idea of the
transmission Network to help us predict
monitor or prevent virus spread into a
larger scale
so the uh there are tons of work that's
been done for modeling very spread on
networks I only list a few of them that
is closely related to the work that I'm
going to present in particular the first
one I listed here uh the epidemic model
with heterogeneous transmission rates
across different groups this is done by
Leo manovich and York this is probably
the first paper that gave a thorough
treatment of these type of models and
identify this threshold condition
another related uh topic is on this
discreet time versus red model where one
knows the exact Network structure and
want to say something about the
stressful condition
these two type of models fall into the
category of me field approximation or
where it assumes the independence of
among the nodes and then um some people
have done some work to study the
approximation error accuracy for me
field approximation and as we have seen
in the previous talks an interesting
problem would be when we look at the
networks we don't know the exact
structure but we have some information
to summarize the networks either through
some random connections uh sort of
degree distribution and others
we can still infer properties about the
word respect
An important method that's relate to
closely to the work here is the message
passing message where
um given the network structure
individuals
um
or let me computed the probability of a
node I in fact in node J and then it's
uh it's called a message or we saw it
through a self-consistent equation
um and based on that individual nodes
summarize over its neighborhood the
compute uh the
probability of infection
so as I mentioned I did not list this is
by no means a full overview of the vast
literature I just point you to some
reference here for other related work
okay so I would like to start with uh
ideal example where we know the
transmission structure so here I Define
an effective transmission link from node
I to node J if
um a virus passes from person I to
person J that actually caused the
infection of non-tip so this is uh sort
of we have a full information on how to
write respect on the network and then
each node has two states
infected uninfected I didn't know Pi the
probability of node I um being infected
uh at time k
so we know that uh with that one can
write the one step update of the
probability of infection on the right
hand side this is the probability of
none of my neighbors are infected and on
the right hand side this is the
probability of node I uh not being
affected here the only actual point one
need to pay attention is that the
neighborhood of node I here I Define it
as the neighborhood with itself included
this is just use this just to make sure
that uh characterizing the fact that
individuals after infection do not
recover in just one step
well um that is very simple now I want
to take a different perspective of the
same problem instead of associating each
node with their probability of infection
now I introduce a new variable that to
associate with the state of the
particular node this I take the minus
log 1 minus pi
uh you'll realize that this actually is
the so-called information content or
Channel information of the event that
node I being healthy at time k
so with this transformation we see that
it is monotone projective and concave
what we do is we take log on both sides
of this equation and take negation now
we arrive a linear Dynamics with the
state as the information content States
for linear system we know how to
analysis we can even write out explicit
to the solution for the S case so it's
just take the power a to the power k n
times the initial condition and with the
same equation uh in relation we can go
back to the probability of infection so
we have so we have now here the message
is that you take a different perspective
we get the linear Dynamics it's easy to
analyze and we can get explicit
Solutions
but now in the real situation we don't
know exactly the network structure then
you just introduce some random or
connections among individuals here I use
the
this picture is a physical contact
Network where two persons have a
connection if they are within a radius
say six feet for 15 minutes at least
and then again each node has a
probability of being infected at that
time do not have jacket
on each link multiple viruses particles
are sent into the common space I denote
the aij as the number of particles sent
from I node I to node.j and not J to
know that and wi represent the
probability of each of these particles
sent from node.j that is successfully
received by node I
so
following the similar ideas I read the
same type of equation where on the right
hand side this is the probability of
none of the particles various particles
original die and on the left is then the
probability of node I being healthy at
time K plus 1. here that I make an
assumption uh sort of
sort of uh the independence assumption
on the uh variables if you think about
the independent
um each individual has a random
event associated with it being housed
and then this was ignoring the
dependence of across different
individuals
and also assume the conditional
Independence of the Transmissions across
different links and the Transmissions
across different various particles
if you want to spend a bit more time on
the interpretations of this model
um it's
um it has the property the Dynamics has
the property that I'm an individual one
of my neighbor is enough to infect me so
this type of Dynamics has this property
with different interpretations of the
aij wig and TI we actually can treat it
for a different application problem I
started with the case where we think
about the contact Network when uh where
we study the probability of individual
get infected in fact one can also think
about it as populations where each node
has is represented City and the AIG then
naturally represented the number of
passengers from node J to know that and
wlg then represents the probability of
each individual passengers from ctj that
infect someone in city city
no one can also think about as some
information spread on social network
where this represents a piece of
information that's original die
and then uh one can
um another interesting interpretation is
that one can uh this with simplifying
assumptions could be thought of as a
connection between two neurons at the
neurotransmitter level where this is a
picture of a typical illustration of a
chemical synapses uh
thank you for
this should be a product at times all
the uh
individual neighborhoods and their
particles in the from the universe
[Music]
um yeah so as we see here
um on the left is presynaptic neural
after excitation it would send a large
population of these uh molecules called
neurotransmitters into the common space
are called the synaptic clef
and then each of these neurotransmitters
have some probability connecting with
these receptors on the postsynaptic
neuron then activate the post-enamic
neuralism probability
now I want to use the same type of idea
that we studied for the trivial example
we start with we have viewed the system
from a different perspective I use the
information content as the states I take
log on both sides of this equation and
take negation on both sides here is also
has to be J
um and then we arrive at a new form of
representing the Dynamics
where the only actual part is this
percent function so non-linear function
that takes an activation level parameter
wij and takes the signal input and State
we call this function per PSI here the
tunable log sigmoid activation function
um I will explain a bit later why we
call it we give it that name but it has
the property when w equal to zero it
represents zero path and W equal to one
this is a full path when w between 0 and
1 this represent a passive pass
uh it also has the nice property where
this function is concave in X which we
will use in uh deriving this threshold
condition uh very easily and then it has
the property that one can write all the
explicit derivatives
so I want to relate this to a standard
review of the neural network that people
like use
nowadays A Lot
the connection is can be done through
follows as follows first we give a
homogeneous parameter for all the wijs
and then we Define a new state which is
the activated states are through this
activation function with the homogeneous
parameter W of your signal with and we
don't we can denote this by Sigma w
ow some nonlinear function activated on
the states now we just plug in this
nonlinear function on both sides of this
equation we get this
uh what it says here you do a linear
summation over your neighbors and you
take a nonlinear activation function
produce the output for that particular
node this is a standard neural network
unit right
so now we see the connection uh if we
specialize in the parameter W to 0.5 we
get this from where this is actually the
log sigmoid activation function and this
is some constant onset
so this is the reason why we call it a
tunable log Sigma and aggravation
function because you get a flexibility
of choosing the parameter
to summarize at this stage we start with
the various red model look like this we
take a different view of the same model
taking the nodal state to be the
information content we get a simple
Dynamics
have this form and the node operation is
does not involve any non-linear
summation uh operations it's only a
linear summation so it's Illustrated
here the signals pass through the
activation functions that has different
activation levels and not only involves
nodal summation
um we realize that if we set this W
parameter to one this become a linear
path which goes back to the first
example I show you and so this seemed to
suggest if one was thinking about the
neural this type of transmission model
in a linearity actually only come from
the probabilistic nature of sending
these particles
so this is a very interesting
interpretation
um it turns out one can be log sigmoid
activation function is not the only
activation function one can associate
with that type of Dynamics
if we restrict our output to be negative
we are essentially doing a threshold on
this activation output then one can
essentially using the positive part of
this curve one have this form of
activation functions and on the right
this one is just a standard rectified
linear unit
if we take a different uh perspective
the state transformation we instead of
taking negative log we here we just take
log uh same analysis analysis go through
it's just we get a different nonlinear
function here
this we call it a tunable self-defined
because it's extend the standard soft
plastic division function the extension
is as follows as you look at this curve
this very it looks as if it's a soft
plus activation but it has some uh
negative leaky parts
if you set the parameter W to 0.5 this
becomes a soft class with some offset
log 0.5
another activation come out naturally
from this is the tunable sigmoid
activation function where you take the
partial derivative of this activation
with respect to the signal input you get
this form looks a bit complicated but if
you check the figure it's quite
straightforward where w0 equal to 0.5
this is the standard sigmoid activation
when w does not equal to 0.5
uh this curve cross the y-axis this
particular point is highlighted in red
here these are actually the parameter
value for w so this gives you a
flexibility of choosing the threshold
value which is exactly the W parameter
here
okay so
um
this different view of this virus spread
model actually give us some um
simplified our analysis about epidemic
threshold condition
so if we ask the question will the virus
die out as time goes to infinite
regardless of initial conditions one can
identify a condition like this basically
all the eigenvalues of the this Matrix a
head amount product of w less than one
in absolute value this simply means
element-wide multiplication of the two
matrices
the analysis is very straightforward
just one slide you use the concavity of
a property of this activation function
in its signal input and we write an
inequality condition and we apply this
into the Dynamics of the transnet we get
the same inequality and we set the
reference point to the origin
now we get this inequality
this is on the right hand side it looks
uh just a linear summation no
nonlinearities and we know that this
inequality is element wise
so we know the state as I will be
bounded by all the states of this linear
system with the same initial condition
and we know the linear system is
globally asymptotically stable if the
spectrum of all the eigenvalues of the
system Matrix are less than one in the
absolute value so now we sort of have an
ideal a very straightforward idea of the
service condition which is
um if we specialize this condition to
the special case where we have a
homogeneous recovery rate
um
and you go back to your serum yeah one
more
not the serum itself
um
I see so it's an if but not an if and
only if
um it's not an if and only if there is a
tricky part when this thing equal to
zero equal to one but when it equals
greater than one we can show that uh
there will be some initial conditions
the words to know that I have dealt so
if you go back to go to your next page
so this proof really only gives if so
this will not give if it's because N1
that you
yeah this is One Direction give one a
sufficient condition the the other
direction one should use the local
perturbations around the origin to get a
this is one kind of problem well this
thing is greater than one uh there will
be some initial conditions where the
verbs do not die out
so um a special case of this uh is where
we have a homogeneous recovery
probability data which is uh we set the
diagonal element of w to 1 minus Theta
we have a homogeneous transmission
probability or infection probability
beta set of diagonal terms of wij 2 Beta
then we can explicitly write out this uh
element-wide product in terms of these
parameters and the Matrix a so then we
get the well-known threshold condition
uh where this fatal diametrics is the uh
is the adjacency Matrix without
self-loops
so another thing we can derive out of
this is look at the continuous time
model for this transmission neural net
uh here when we look at this free time
version of it we haven't make any
assumptions on the wig with respect to
time duration for transmission if we
make an extra assumption that this thing
roughly skills uh linearly in small time
duration and then take the small time
limit and get the continuous time model
and here these coefficients a cij is the
basic transmission probability rate per
unit time from j2i and CII is the
self-healing probability rate per unit
time
um this model has a nice uh interesting
feature is is that uh we don't see
product term of isi times I stay on the
right hand side
now use the same relation between the
state s and the probability of infection
we plug this into that immediately we
get the continuous Time network sis
model
but here the difference that one
actually get a product term on the right
hand side
to summarize at this stage uh we start
with the discrete timer respect model
that has this product form we take a
different view of the system uh
represent the state as the information
content we arrive something roughly
linear or a summation of a non-linear
activated signals and then with further
assumptions on these
wws how um the transmission probability
we assume that is roughly linear in time
duration taking small time limits we get
a continuous time version of this model
use the same state transformation that
gave us back to the standard Network SS
model
so sort of this Loop shows you these are
actually consistent models as a under
this assumption
um so we can think about this uh as we
mentioned earlier these are actually
um neural networks so we can treat them
as learning models one first question I
would ask is are these Universal
functional approximators
um like a set of it's a universal
function approximator is uh probably a
set of a function of a set of
parameterized function uh is called a
universal functional proximator for
continuous functions from
a p dimensional input to m-dimensional
Output if for any small Epsilon for any
compact subset in the input space any
function that defined from this compact
subset to the outer space or continuous
function we can identify a member in the
parameter size function that is uh
arbitrally close to the
continuous Function One choose so this
means that we can use this set of
functions to approximate continuous
functions arbitrary well
here is an example to illustrate uh
these properties with one transnet with
one hidden layer
take the simple case where we have D
dimensional input or just a scalar
output
here the structure looks at this we have
the signal input each of them are rated
by their coordinates and then come into
the node has a summation form uh
actually we have a fixed bias term that
comes into the node the node only take a
summation
and then the output of the node gets
into these activated links with
different activation parameter w
here are these parameters on and the AI
and wi and I highlighted in blue these
are the tunable parameters
there is an interesting aspect of here
is that we associate these linear
connections with an activation with
level uh activation level one
this is also different from the standard
Universal function approximator result
for these structures where one
also require pip to be a tunable
parameter so each node will have a
different bias time here we don't
require that because we have tunable
activation w
ow
so
um for that uh if these are the choice
range for their parameters and this
model we can use the same same type of
proof so that this is actually a
universal function approximator
um so here is an example uh if you think
um how to look at this as multiple step
or you have several steps on neural
networks we look at treat the same
system we give the initial system
initial State as the out input we look
at some finite Horizon the uh the output
that time T will be considered at the
output as the output of the this
transplant model
so the objective is then giving these
initial conditions as the input data and
we want to compare the observation of
the system output with the labels and
then plus some
regularization cost and we want to find
the parameter in your parameter set that
minimize this uh cost
the standard view of the surprise
learning uh and now the observations we
can associate that through our state
transformation to link the state back to
the probability that the particular node
is being active
and we can also pick a small subset of
the output through this observation
if you want to I want to input and
output have different dimensions
to incorporate this thing to the
recurrent neural network structure of
the grapheneur network structure which
can do similar similar things the key is
to use these uh three tunable activation
functions by using these tunable
activation functions one can associate
the probability of activation that we
start with the wireless fat model
and the second aspect is think this link
activity states by which I mean these
are the link activated States and we
take the summation
so on the advantage of using this as a
learning model as I already explained uh
uh with earlier that we can have a
notional probability of note being
negative naturally building into the
model a second aspect is that if you set
these parameters set these activation
parameters as part of the trainable
parameter then you get an automatic
selection of the activation functions
through a range of activations where
some of them actually include the the
standard activation function as a
special case
uh and then the flexibility of thinking
about uh activation with links that you
can associate a different link with
different activation levels and you can
also think about problems where a fixed
the graph structure and I only tune the
activation uh activation level for that
particular link
so this is uh the end of my talk so we
discussed uh transnet as well respect
models we discussed the threshold
condition that easily come out of it and
we
um so this different view of the various
model naturally linked the discrete time
version of
network sis model with the continuous
Time network SRS model
and we
um also discussed the property of
universal function approximator of
transnet as learning models and we I
introduced you three different uh
activation functions where where uh that
are associated with this um structure
and it has the nice property that one
can automatically tune the activation
functions and we have natural
interpretations of node uh activation
level node activation probability that
come out of the output
uh so moving on for future work the
first thing
um I'm investigating is the control and
modulation of these uh models both in
the learning setting and the epidemic
setting
uh so here is sort of the control
variables one can associate with the
um transnet to view it as a very respect
model so all these are different uh
control variables naturally fitting the
framework in particular if one thing
about the case of bearing mask you have
an invert and outward efficacy and
it so if you multiply the efficacy on
the left of w i j this represents the
invert efficacy of the variable mask if
you associate it to the right of the
aijs representing a number of various
particles you'll send that means the
outward uh Associated naturally the
outward efficacy
one can think about uh social distancing
vaccination treatment the case for
treatment is you give a particular way
of modifying the diagonal elements of
the W Matrix
everyone can also think about the global
modulation where simultaneously we
change a set of parameters for different
links
another question of interest is to look
at the random realizations of these
connections and the random realization
of the states here the type of model
that I will present to you as treating
these connections at really
probabilities and we propagate the
probability but we never realized these
random uh Connections in random States
so there could be there will be some
error and then it's of great interest
both in academics and in learning
setting
another important thing is to treat the
inhibition and plasticity of these
connections
primarily motivated by modeling on
biological neural networks
um
an interesting question one can ask can
we use this relation between a learning
model and the viruspect model to really
learn the very respect respecting the
local graph structures given some input
output data
um and then another work that I've been
doing is to look at if we can uh how to
apply this on same type of
Transformations or same type of views to
more complicated model where one can
associate individual knows with multiple
States the exposed the states uh recover
the state and associated with feature
low location and age
okay so that's the end uh thank you for
your attention
okay questions
so
so this was a very interesting thought
my first question and maybe a comment is
that it might not be so simple to
somehow tune this system so so how would
you
how would you relate this to some data
from an epidemic right now okay how you
know and
what would be the the way in which you
would maybe try to
[Music]
validate this on on some specific
structure or at least on some specific
data Series right
um I mean this is something I'm thinking
about but one of the things I think
would be interesting is that if the uh
sort of doing some context racing we
have some ideas of a local structure and
then I put that local structure in the
model and also I observed some of the
probabilities of the uh infections and
she said and some input out of data have
a fake model for each time step maybe
that gave us some way to train the
Panthers
um I mean I think this is a great
question I don't have a complete answer
but that's just an example let me go
back to the page as a model is defined
so for our academics people what would
you call this kind of model is it
the screen Services
yeah it kind of looks like a master
equation for the you know through
the epidemic process do you mean yes no
no not this one the other one the
continuous time one yeah
I think it's called the Midfield uh in
the region based on Mayfield Network sis
right so so this is a version of a mean
field equation
it's a little similar to what we would
call a master equation which basically
describes the the instantaneous rate of
infection
but the master question is is exactly
Master equation is exact in the sense
that that this it completely describes
the the the endemic
whereas this is some kind of nature
right so so it's not exactly a master
equation but it's Master equation like
you basically want to explore the
dependence across different nodes
otherwise there will be some
uh correlations
yeah so the good question and so so how
would you you know use this type of
representation
to try to validate your model right or
or is there some simple way in which you
do
let me ask you about this more basic
questions the third view but I use this
transactions that what's the what
I'm proposing this as a way to model the
spirit of epidemic side networks or this
is just a new architecture that you're
introducing for any learning task what
application do you have in mind for this
architecture so um first this thing uh
the the this architecture that can apply
to any neural network take one this
simple trigger that we mentioned here
but the simple trick is that one use is
a different view of the network
architecture link the activation level
to a particular links and that can be
building into any of the machine
learning model that is using neural
networks
um basically the key factor is the
aggregation function that can't give us
a natural interpretation of not being
active or the probability
or implement this so where would be the
first place when you draw what sort of
learning tasks do you so I think some
experiment on the image recognition but
that requires lots of engineering to get
the feature of the image but that was
the first thing that it was uh I
actually tried to see the
effective element of tool or activation
function it turns out to be very good
um but for others I think I was
initially I was thinking to compare this
for starting them thanks for uh
epidemics brand where what have you seen
a kind of casting time models which
actually taken into this consideration
and the dependence and approximation
loans and then this Mickey Mouse some
approximation and at least this would be
validate and be this was something
that's useful and then for really
applying to study an academic problem I
don't have a complete answer like this
is because it depends on what kind of
data that we have
all right
so so let me try to understand this for
the epidemic model so what you could
think of is that I have this s i of zero
and the s i of K and I would sort of
I would
expect propagate in my network in my
neural network to learn the way it's to
actually the produce The observed
epidemics right is that what you could
intrinsically do yeah
if I had sort of if I knew who was
infected at time zero and I saw
everybody was infected at the end
this should be a way to use the standard
neural network technology to have a
candidate Network
but you would have to observe your
epidemic Until the End right or you
would have to look forward and sort of
whatever your case right yeah right so
much of that because if I understood
so SI is related to Pik which is a
priority that I is the Infectious type
okay so you propagate your probabilities
but if you have data on the path so it
changes because you have conditional
probabilities on the path and it seems
to me that it's very nice I like YouTube
very much and but it seems to me that
Trump also of Corrections for example if
I really know that into your eye is
infectious
I cannot use my equations anymore
because if we should just keep the the
probability of being infectious when I
help something so to answer the question
of I mean I think that
um I I don't pretend to answer the
question but I have that the impression
that um a utility of this model would be
first you have an epidemic and you want
to give people more at risk like in a
week and Europe you could run this uh
this network model and it tells you
given the possibilities of each India to
be infectious what would be what would
be the more you should you could run
your energy your body so so it's more
like it's a one-step model right it also
looks the next time
it's so you're saying it's like we can
simulate an epidemic
I'm not sure if it's right at the
beginning because if I understand it
does not keep track of Corrections or
second order information yeah it doesn't
keep track of the second order
information but this thing also gives
you an upper account for the probability
of infections
um so regarding to your question that's
uh did you reset this at each time step
we make an observation I think if you're
right each time I observed from lately I
realized the event
um and then I should propagate the
information starting with a New
Foundation
um I think very many the other idea is
that if we know relatively well the
connection structure where this game
does not change that much over time then
you have a fixed structure maybe you can
use one little bit how to learn the
structure ntk from the activation link
for different connections
company
okay
um awesome questions
so it's really it's a neat field
approximation
and I think it's still different it is
different because it's not taking into
account the the sort of the correlations
left again
but here there are some if you think
these are the random variables at times
and the problem is that we take
expectation on the left and then the
expectation cannot come into the product
so here is where the Sacrifice from the
first expectations to come into the
products
right so so in that sense it's not a
material approximation because you're
assuming independent
some people call it more like a tree
yeah
so what does it mean well it doesn't
mean that that you are you have some
sort of sparse infection
[Music]
Effectiveness you are assuming
Independence
what does this in terms of graph
structure or in terms of you know some
features
okay
I think it means that if we start from
some initialization which are initially
independent we probably get one step on
the network uh The Next Step the states
will be treated as random variables they
are correlated that depends on your
previous variable state of the ideas
right if you come from the same neighbor
support your related to you don't come
from the same neighbors then we are soon
okay so so there is some kind of
assumption about the history of the
process that that says that somehow the
dependence are interdependence of these
infections doesn't matter for a while
sort of like massive message
neighbors are independent
foreign
foreign
[Music]
opportunity on dense Network actually
sees the main field of your neighbors
and not
that's what he's got that's
called as pain all the product of C6 is
a century the average effect of your
neighbors on you
and the W has to be constant right
foreign
stupid Marks here so
um
I think this would sort of
be quick
yeah
I'm just not familiarism
I'm afraid my eyesight is not great at
this distance without glasses
we just multiplying the probability of
escaping infection from each of the
neighbors yeah right yeah
five seconds
looking at the actual neighborhood
so
it's not the state of the notes the
probability so if you're taking the
product
that starts whether they're independent
Photoshop
I said yeah if it was a random event for
sure but you said it's the probability
yeah exactly
is less than equal to the
um
questions
foreign
[Music]
should be
it's
you can do this for all the other
parents
[Music]
but there will be an error which I don't
know how to characterize
but not do we know that on general
elections that the probability of being
affected are positively correlated yes I
probably did
foreign
foreign
[Music]
it's
all right
okay we got some cookies to get the
sugar wake us up for late Friday
afternoon